[Music]
my wardrobe is kind of limited
but I tried to make them appropriate to
the talk so this is my impression of a
black hole
[Applause]
it's all improvement from here on um
take two our speaker tonight is one of
the world's leading astrophysicists and
she says that these decades are a golden
age of cosmology and by that she means
that the really profound mysteries are
turning up and the questions are coming
faster than the answers and she's in the
thick of finding the answers Priya
Natarajan
[Applause]
okay first of all it's a real honor and
a privilege to have the opportunity to
talk to you all today and what I am
hoping to do in my talk this evening is
to try and give you in some sense a
status report of what we know about the
key ingredients of our universe
so one of the reasons I'm sorry giving
you this preamble you might have already
guessed is that we simultaneously know
quite a lot and not a lot and this is a
situation that as scientists we have to
constantly live with and it's part of
the exciting enterprise of doing science
practice of science that the minute you
have a really good well-formed theory
we're on our way to try and disrupt it
to use a Silicon Valley term we want to
actually change it we want new evidence
that would possibly invalidate it
so we're cause we are sort of constantly
moving the bar in trying to understand
quantities that have been very hard to
figure out and the minute we do we want
to sort of get rid of them and try to
see if something new something better
something that's a better description
that has more explanatory power can
replace that so I'm hoping to show you
some of that process as well because
that is that is what the day to day work
of a scientist like me and often people
ask me when I'm sitting in my office I'm
often just sitting and staring into
space actually and they you know I'm
waiting for that window of inspiration
where something will kind of click and
you never know when it's gonna come and
so my students walk past and they say
okay she doesn't seem busy
but then they're really scared and they
come in and I say oh yeah I am actually
busy okay so I'm hoping to sort of
convey some of the excitement of what we
actually do so the essential is
invisible to the eyes says the Fox in
the little prince' it's one of my
favorite stories
and so the human imagination right we've
always been fascinated with the
invisible and the unseen entities so
earlier on in the medieval ages it was
ether it was miasma it was Fletcher
stone and these were all shown to be
non-existent but wait so are we done
with invisible forces in the universe so
it turns out nope
in fact more than ever our worldview and
our understanding of the cosmos hinges
on unseen quantities and I'm gonna try
to show you that these are different
these entities dark matter and dark
energy are not gonna go the way of ether
okay we don't think so because we have a
lot of independent lines of evidence
that suggest that they are real of
course you know one is always open to
surprises and nature might quite
surprises and we may be able to have a
breakthrough that disrupt this entire
notion of definition of dark matter and
maybe there's a new theory that doesn't
need these ingredients and need
something else so let me um first before
I move on the work that I have been
doing and the work that a lot of our
scientists have been doing is never done
alone right this troupe of this single
scientist with unkempt hair thinking
great thoughts it doesn't work anymore
we all work in collaborations and I just
wanted to acknowledge a lot of the
people many of my students and postdocs
who over the years have contributed to a
lot of the results that I'm going to
show you here my results some of my
results I'm going to show I'm going to
give you paint a broader picture than
just what I do and the there are many of
them are former and current students at
Yale former postdocs and I've also been
very fortunate to have gotten funding
from NASA and NSF and the Guggenheim
Foundation and so on so I'd like to
acknowledge that okay so before I go on
to tell you what is peculiar about the
dark components in our universe
let me just first before I disorient you
and tell you let me give you the sort of
the comforting idea first which is that
we have a really good sense at the
moment of cosmic history we have a
really nice story that is backed up by
evidence and some of it incontrovertible
evidence and essentially what we now
know is that our universe is roughly
13.8 billion years old and it started
off very early on set off by what is a
misnomer a Big Bang it was not really an
explosion but it started off where we
define T equals 0 start of time there
was a brief period of exponential
expansion the inflationary era and then
after that we had an epoch when the
universe the energy of the universe was
dominated by radiation that we now see
as the Cosmic Microwave Background and
then there was an epoch where matter
started to dominate the inventory of the
universe and drive its fate and then
today more recently we find that the
fate of the universe is driven by dark
energy this unseen mysterious force that
we'll be talking about now these two
dark these two components so much of the
matter in the universe is dark matter so
the majority no more than 90% of the
matter constituents of the universe are
dark matter and what is special about
dark matter is that it does not couple
to any radiation so you see no photons
in any wavelength coming from any
interaction with a dark matter particle
it likely very weakly couples to stuff
to itself we don't know at the moment
and it's not made of ordinary atoms so
this is stuff that is not on the
periodic table this is not stuff that
was synthesized in the Centers of stars
as far as we know this was just some
exotic particle that was formed very
early in the universe the interesting
thing as you I will show you today is we
know a lot of things about dark matter
quite exquisitely how it's spatially
distributed for example but how it
aggregates how it evolves over time how
it shapes the end
universe in fact it shapes the entire
universe but we don't know what that
particle is and that's what is very
troubling about the problem I mean we
you know we are making progress and I
think I'll show you what the latest is
on so the only thing that we do know
about dark matter is that it has these
particles have mass and therefore they
have gravity and it's the gravitational
effect that dark matter exerts on
particles that we can actually see
radiation from in its vicinity that have
given us the clue to the existence of
dark matter so I'll spend some more time
I sort of lay out the land of how we've
actually discovered dark matter and dark
energy and so the two ways in which dark
matter has revealed itself is by the
dynamical effect that it has on stars
and other galaxies in the universe and
the other way in which we have found
dark matter is the fact that matter
bends light and so by the bending of
light has been light as our so the
photons are a cosmic messenger
everything we know about the universe
has come really from photons and so and
dark matter all matter in fact has a
very profound effect on the paths of
photons in the universe as we will just
see so these are sort of the two
independent lines of evidence and it
turns out that even dark energy it's the
same I mean because dark energy as we
will just see is a mysterious force or
repulsive force that counteracts gravity
that is accelerating the expansion rate
of the universe today and its effects
are found not by the effect it has on
individual galaxies or individual stars
the motions of individual stars but the
motion of the entire universe right so
it's sort of scaled up if you will
abstract and more powerful force in some
ways definitely more mysterious at the
moment but before I proceed there are a
couple of preliminaries that might be
useful to to cover so that you know the
the kinds of evidence that I'm going to
be summoning to show you that dark
matter is real so for example we can
focus on as I said light is the cosmic
messenger and the couple of properties
of the transmission of light in the
universe that are sort of relevant to
our understanding of dark matter is the
fact that when we look out into the
night sky and I find this fact still
quite incredible in all making but when
you look out into the night sky with the
largest telescopes that we have on earth
we're actually looking back in time the
so the deeper we look the farther back
in time we can access right and the
universe is expanding at a pretty fast
clip today right and as I just mentioned
dark energy appears to be the energy
that is powering this expansion now any
expansion of the universe will stretch
wavelengths of light and so the graphic
here suppose our universe was the space
in our universe approximates say the
outside of a sphere I'm not saying that
that's what our universe is but an
example a nice visualization is then you
can see that as the sphere experience
and you are seeing the paths of photons
these wavelengths that are shown here
they get stretched out and what we
really measure from the stretching out
of this wavelength which is called
redshift we can actually measure
distances and we can actually measure
even the expansion history of the
universe itself
by looking at this so for example when
we look back in time we can look at the
spectrum the energy that's coming from
the sum of all the stories in a galaxy
we can look at the spectrum that is of a
galaxy that's nearby versus one that's
farther away and we can actually
calibrate where they are by looking at
the stretching of the fingerprints of
the atoms that we actually know so
thankfully for us in the universe
physical laws are invariant so an
hydrogen atom here and the transition
energy transition levels that you have
on earth are the same on Andromeda or
any other distinct galaxy thankfully for
us right and so because we have that
calibration one we see the stretched
wavelengths we can kind of figure out
how far an object is and how fast it's
moving away from us
and so the spectra which are for distant
galaxies that we can measure so you can
measure both the expansion of the
universe and any systemic local motions
that they have both of these can be sort
of disentangled and measured compared to
a nearby standard and so this is a sort
of key in terms of how these
measurements are made right so it's
actually from a lot of it is from
spectra anyway so Newton did something
quite remarkable when he was able to
connect to the celestial and the
terrestrial which is with his universal
theory of gravitation so he conceived of
gravity what he came up with is how
gravity acts what he didn't come up with
is what gravity is right I mean so but
he gave us a really nice explanation for
how gravity works so you have a body of
mass M 1 another body of mass M 2
separated by some distance D and the
force of gravity exerted by one on the
other is proportional to product of the
masses over the distance square right so
was it so you know the Aintree incite
we're looking for patterns on the sky
and they were not looking for an
explanation the reason this was
remarkable was that it was after bra hey
and Kepler onwards that we've been
looking at the night sky not discerning
just patterns but wanting an explanation
so Kepler and bra he put us on this
track of trying to find an explanation
and Newton came up with this incredible
operational description for gravity and
he ruled for 200 years and then Einstein
came along and appended him Einstein
came up with a fundamental of it was not
an incremental sophistication a slight
refinement in Newton's theory this was a
fundamental reshaping a fundamental
reconceptualizing of the cosmos in fact
the entire cosmos so the general theory
of relativity that he published in 1916
it is actually applicable to all kinds
of all scales all astronomical scales
gravitation and gravitating systems
black holes planetary systems in fact
the entire universe and that was what
was audacious about it that this was one
theory that actually in which and I will
show you the equation I think this crowd
might actually like that equation
it's a beautiful compact equation to
have the audacity to think that you
could actually write quantities
pertinent to the entire universe on the
right hand side and the entire universe
on the left hand side and say that they
could be equal I mean that was what was
remarkable and the profound the profound
connection underlying all of this is a
profound connection between mass and
space so in Einstein's version of
gravity so Einstein actually came up
with an explanation for gravity and his
explanation was the presence of mass
creates curvature in space times we
conceived of space as a four-dimensional
entity and because he realized cosmic
scales in order to describe an event
that occurs at any point you need to
specify not just where it happened but
when it happened because the speed of
light although large is finite and in
order to uniquely pin when events happen
you need to know all four coordinates so
this led to this sort of geometric
conception of this entity called
space-time and you know and they're sort
of cliched way of saying that is space
curvature tells masses how to move and
mass creates curvature in space so it is
curvatures in space-time that actually
causes masses to move right and
space-time is where we live everything
in the universe is space-time there's
nothing above space-time there's nothing
below space-time therefore if we are
thinking of photons or light rays
traveling in the universe they are
confined to space-time so one of the key
breakthroughs with Einsteins thinking
was the way in which he linked he was
able to link with his field equations
the contents the geometry and the fate
the the evolution over time of the
entire universe so I should quickly
point out here that you know Einstein
was actually not very happy with an
expanding you
he really liked the static universe of
the Ancients and he tried really hard to
keep the universe static even though
there was overwhelming evidence as I'll
just show from Hubble from data
empirical evidence in it was you
couldn't dispute it and it took him a
long time to actually sort of let go and
say okay you know I can live with the
universe that is expanding so Einstein's
theory of general relativity now we see
that it explains not just our it our
cosmic inventory dark matter and dark
energy but it also tells us that there
is a fundamental link between the
geometry of space-time and the contents
and the measurable expansion history of
the universe it's it's a medicine
observable quantity it's something that
you can measure and you can also measure
the contents of the universe the
inventory of the universe can be taken
so if you do those things so of these
three quantities if you know two you can
actually determine what the geometry is
for example right now the evidence for
dark matter comes hinges from the
application of this version of gravity
the need for dark matter arises even if
we think of gravity a la Newton but the
compelling evidence comes from the
general theory of relativity because it
allows us to actually measure and relate
these three quantities as I said you
know they're all empirically measurable
quantities so today what I'm going to
focus on in terms of cosmic objects that
are going to help us understand the
nature of dark matter and dark energy
are these objects called clusters of
galaxies and they're the most massive
assemble structures in the universe they
have a mass a total mass which is in
excess of 10 to the 15 times the mass of
the Sun and I particularly like these
objects because they can help us measure
both dark matter and dark energy
so although
the measurement of dark energy the
discovery of dark energy did not happen
with clusters of galaxies the objects
that were used to discover them are
supernovae and I in the audience today
we have the Guru of the field
Bob Kirchner supernova attended class of
supernovae that are like standard light
bulbs were used to actually measure the
geometry of the universe and that's how
dark energy was discovered however today
I'll be focusing on a different and a
new way a slightly more challenging way
but in my opinion it's sort of rich
rewards because you kind of get you know
two things for the price of one you can
actually get a dark matter and dark
energy simultaneously it's it's of
course therefore complicated but if we
can do it so just to get back to this
notion of space-time as I said it's a
four dimensional sheet four dimensional
entity you have three space coordinates
in one time and just to show you the
effect of masses on space-time so if you
an object as a flat space no mass no
undulations no divots no potholes if you
have the Sun you see this sort of curve
in space-time and if you have an object
that's more dense like a neutron star
notice that the curvature is stronger
and then of course you have these
enigmatic objects in the universe very
very compact black holes they actually a
puncture in space-time so this is the
effect in terms of what mass is doing to
space-time and so this are Einstein's
equations and I just could not resist
putting them on a slide for you so just
to show you that you know these
quantities it's a beautiful shorthand
for a very large number ten equations
and so what it's showing you is this GME
or new term that's the curvature that's
the shape of space this team you know is
the mass energy content of the universe
and then this other peculiar term is the
vacuum energy of the universe this is
sort of the ground state energy of
space-time itself if you will and so the
properties of the universe space-time
and we're going to be looking in the
context of this sort of shape of space
mass and what must us to space
the propagation of light in the universe
what what the implications are for light
propagation in the universe because
light is really the messenger of all all
measurements are made with light really
and of course you know this equation
also predicts the existence of black
holes and gravitational waves and you
know you might have all seen the recent
excitement that you know black holes
finally became real we saw the direct
detection of gravitational waves from
emerging black holes that have revealed
that these entities exist right because
these black holes solutions so the
solutions to this equation right so the
black hole solution is one exact
solution to this equation
it describes the space-time geometry
around a very very compact object so
another set of solutions to this
equation actually describe the entire
universe and its expansion history and
its contents and that actually comes out
of these this is the last set of
equations before you all say oh my god
okay so so it comes out of these two
equations and one of the sort of key
assumptions to get this is an exact
solution so what's really interesting is
Einstein never thought that there would
be exact solutions to these equations he
said oh there'll be some approximate
solutions and so when these solutions
were found by Alexander Friedmann he
didn't like them
well he didn't like them because the
universe was not static right these were
sort of time if time evolving equations
which he was not happy about but even he
came around to it he tried very hard to
make them static and the way in which he
made them static is by adding this
lambda term that I showed you in the
field equations as well so these two
terms is what Einstein added in so they
sort of mimic some kind of repulsive
force that would counterbalance gravity
and then keep the universe static and it
turns out we've kind of come full circle
in terms of how we interpret that
quantity so just to give you a feel for
the solutions for the expanding universe
so we have the cosmological principle is
sort of an underlying answer right so
that's our baseline which is we see what
every other observer so no observer is
unique in the universe there's no
particular special vantage point so we
all see the same stuff and so for
homogeneous and isotropic universes the
expansion and contraction
you can have both expansion and
contraction mathematically the solutions
right the question is you have the set
of solutions which one best describes
our universe right the one that we live
in and the way to think about the
solutions of expansion and contraction
is to sort intuitively you can see right
gravity is attractive it would tend to
kind of pull things together and if you
want to be GR savvy it creates these
potholes and therefore masses can masses
will feel the curvature and move
accordingly right whereas if you have a
repulsive force you tend to stretch out
space-time instead of causing a divot
you actually stretch it out so in a way
the solutions that give you a expansion
and contraction can be sort of
attributed to the sort of the tussle
between these two forces so in 1929 to
1935 Huggle Edwin Hubble discovered that
galaxies bar bar one every other galaxy
in our vicinity well of course he first
figured out that there were other
external galaxies even that was not
known right at the time it was believed
that we lived we were the only we were
alone and what this was this one
galaxies all there was in the universe
but he realized well he found more than
realized it's empirical data you know
this is not a very convincing straight
line but you know he had there was a
leap of faith and you know the points
filled in but I wanted to show you the
first plot that he published so he
noticed that their velocity with which
galaxies were receding away from us was
directly proportional to their distance
from us so that's the velocity we and
that's the distance or and this H is
called the Hubble constant so to give
you a better sense of what it really
means to talk about expanding space
because this is going to underlie you
know all the measurements that I'm gonna
talk about that give you evidence for
dark matter and dark energy
so when space expands it's like having a
grid and the entire grid expands so
you're not expanding into something and
that's a very common misconception so
the entire grid kind of expands and
remember the grid is everything there's
nothing above there's nothing below so
you know it's a four dimensional
my fault okay so there are three
distinct solutions three distinct
possibilities for universes three
combinations of fate geometry and
contents for the universe and they're
encapsulated here in terms of the
expansion scale of the universe how the
expansion rate changes over cosmic time
so you have these three possibilities
that three solutions and again the quest
of observational cosmology is to try and
figure out which one we are on which one
is our universe on right and of course
there is also correspondingly three
different options for the geometry of
the universe right so one is the outside
of a sphere the other is my favorite
which is Pringle chip and saddle
it's a favorite because of my fondness
for Pringle chips not because the
universe is actually a saddle and the
other of course is a flat geometry so
and you know this is sort of very simple
kind of notions that we can understand
we're essentially how do you
discriminate these right I mean the
whole idea is we want observations to be
able to discriminate which of these
solutions were not so how do you
determine this you can see for example
if you're on the outside of a sphere the
sum of the angles of a triangle are not
going to add up to 180 degrees so if you
can kind of make some measurements you
can figure out what kind of surface
corresponds to a surface that best
describes our universe so so now we
actually have a full inventory of the
universe and this is where the
bizarreness starts okay so we look at so
we the ordinary atoms that were made of
all the stuff in the periodic table you
know the stuff that was synthesized in
the first three minutes of the universe
that is up to lithium-7 and then
everything else that was synthesized in
the periodic table in the Centers of
stars you know all this sort of romantic
stuff we are made of Stardust yes that's
awesome but we're only 4.6 percent of
this whole of this inventory 23 percent
and you know ninety more than 90 percent
of the materpiece is actually dark
matter which I told you does not
any radiation does not emit it only has
gravity and we don't know what the
particle is and the rest the 72% in blue
is dark energy this is the force the
mysterious force that is pulling
everything apart and causing the
accelerating expansion of the universe
now my further if one of the interesting
thing is I've been talking about these
the universe and the solutions not being
static right they're valving in time so
if you look when the universe was about
roughly 400,000 years old so we now have
data from which we can infer what the
components were how much they
contributed at that time and we actually
now know that at the time the inventory
was slightly different dark energy was
not very consequential at that time it
hadn't come into play right it kind of
kicks into gear very late in the
universe okay so this was the standard
sort of the discovery of dark energy the
plot that shows the so the way dark
energy was discovered as I said you have
these standard light poles these type 1a
supernovae that are very bright and
therefore can be spotted out to great
distances in the universe and we know
their standard light bulbs you know give
or take there's a little bit of you know
further physics that needs to go in to
make to standardize them and to
understand some of the systematics but
essentially the idea is that it was
found that supernovae were fainter than
our expectation if the only thing that
would be causing the dimming was the one
over R square fall off with distance and
you know people try to explain this away
maybe there's dust maybe there's
something else going on so it turns out
that two independent teams around the
world discovered they had a few
supernovae in common but not very many
they even had completely different
supernovae different data from two
different hemispheres and they arrived
at the same conclusion and this very
bizarre conclusion very uncomfortable
conclusion which I think we again
rapidly accepted scientifically right
there was not as much pushback why
because there were two independent teams
with very compelling evidence right and
they did not share methods or analysis
over
was completely independent and they
arrived at the same conclusion and so I
mean and I think this is a remarkable
this is one of the most remarkable
recent discoveries that has reshaped our
view of the cosmos it's radical and as
I've told you we don't know what dark
energy is right
this is empirical evidence that there's
something going on that is causing the
accelerating expansion of the universe
so we don't actually know if there is a
field at some point that kicks into gear
that you know starts moves changes the
inventory suddenly starts to become
important we roughly know when it starts
to kick into gear but we don't actually
know why and how and we don't know if
it'll go on forever will it stop etc etc
okay so so it's a it's a remarkable
discovery and it has implications it has
very very significant implications for
our cosmic future as well as it tells us
something quite specific about our past
and that inventory that I showed you
when I first started and I said okay
here's the comfortable part of the story
so it actually describes the solution
that best matches our universe is one in
which the universes are rapidly
accelerating today it was radiation
dominated earlier dominated by dark
matter after that and then dark energy
takes over so we know that that's the
universe we are living in and for the
far future there are very interesting
implications right so the universe is
gonna get lonelier and lonelier because
the accelerating expansion our nearby
galaxies are going to be further and
further out so it's going to become a
more desolate place I mean we're talking
billions and billions of years so I mean
it's not anytime soon but um the one of
the advantages of working in cosmology
is that somehow when people tell you oh
I'll see you in 15 minutes and you're
like yeah okay that's nothing right
because I think in mega years I think in
millions of years or billions of years
yeah sure so yeah one has to recalibrate
calibrate sort of reality and say okay
and someone will ask me so how quickly
do two galaxies merge in the universe
you know sort of a new suppose there's a
new image and I'll say oh that's going
to be very
rapid it's just five million years and
so so I think you know cosmic scales are
incredible and I think they're actually
very humbling because you know we live
in the sort of Anthropocene period where
everything revolves around us and you
suddenly realize that our lifespan it's
not even a blip right it's not even a
blip but we are very consequential
because we have the cognitive capacity
to have figured all of this out right I
mean that is incredible
okay so this is coming back so this is
where what a current cosmic picture is
that there was there was some early so
you know there are lots of gaps we don't
know a lot of things I'm sweeping over
many things that we don't know as well
so but we know where we stand with the
data so let me just now dive right into
the devlins for dark matter so the
evidence for dark matter I'm going to
show you is going to be from the impact
that dark matter has on dynamics the
motions of stars
it's a gravitational impact and the
impact on the bending of light rays and
similarly if the evidence for dark
energy that I'm going to show you
because I'm going to be looking at this
particular set of objects called
clusters of galaxies again its impact on
dynamics now of the entire universe it's
not individual objects but the entire
sort of an expansion of scale and it's
of course the impact on the bending of
light rays as well okay so what is the
compelling evidence so if you look at
the solar system and you look at gravity
in the solar system you see that the
speeds and you plot up the speeds of
planets around the Sun you see it's a
nice declining graph Saturn is moving
much slower than Venus is and so on so
forth and this is because the major
gravitating body in the solar system is
the Sun and it's lying at the center and
as you fall off it's a pretty good
Newtonian one over R square kind of
description right so Newton is good
enough for this sort of broad-brush
picture and so what do you expect so
this thing is called a rotation curve so
it's just a fancy way to say velocity is
a function of distance and it's
declining okay as we go further away
from the Sun so the question is if you
go out and do the same measurement for
galaxies and now you measure the speeds
of stars away from the center of a
galaxy what do you see it turns out so
this is the top view of a galaxy or
galaxy for which such a measurement was
made
as a function of radius you're looking
at the speeds of starch this is a spiral
galaxy and what do you see you actually
see this okay completely
counterintuitive completely different so
Vera Rubin and Kent Ford in the 1970s
actually made these measurements for
many spiral galaxies and actually they
sat on the data because they were a
little uncomfortable with the
interpretation of what this meant
because you this is suggestive that
there is something that is distributed
throughout the galaxy that beyond
visible stars beyond the mass and
visible star because you see the stories
you can weigh them you can weigh them
and you can figure out how much they
weigh and this so there's some other
gravitating component that is holding up
the stories in the galaxy and so it
turns out that this is dark matter and
we now and it is not just a one-hit
wonder you see it in most galaxies so
it's not like it is one peculiar class
of galaxies where you see it and you
don't see it it's generic you see it
everywhere pretty much every galaxy
there is very strong evidence that
galaxies are a huge repository of dark
matter so I'm just want to show you some
of the real data so this is from the
original paper in 1978 which they
finally published and you could see that
you know they had these curves going out
to quite far in fact they were starting
to probe distances away from the center
where they run out of stars but you see
gas so the gas motions also reflect the
gravity of whatever is there that's
holding the system together and they
found that the rotation curves were flat
and the only explanation for that is
that you have some gravitating mass all
the way out and so this is our current
sophisticated conception of a galaxy so
we think that every galaxy what we
really end up seeing is a very small
percent of its mass which is visible
stars in the center and everything else
do you have a very extended distribution
of dark matter you have a halo and you
may ask does the halo actually stop it
turns out that it doesn't quite stop it
kind of oozes cosmic link so there isn't
like a sharp edge but you know this is a
sophisticated cartoon okay so let me
quickly move on to the other line of
evidence that I'm going to show you for
for dark matter and dark energy and you
know general relativity celebrated the
centennial last year
and you know this the celebration of
this whole set of equations that have
transformed our cosmic view and what one
consequence because of the potholes and
space-time that are now going to be
created by the existence of presence of
masses photons or light that travels to
us from any point in the universe to us
will actually track and follow every
divert every pothole as it reaches us
right because remember the space-time is
everything there's nothing above it
can't fly but there's nothing above or
below our universe in space-time and so
I Stine was actually able to calculate
that in general relativity and he showed
what the deflection angle but you know
Newton was a smart chap right so
although he didn't he didn't he thought
light was not waves he didn't you know
the the whole sort of wave nature of
light was not understood he imagined
light to be called Pascal's some
particles that had mass and so he said
well if these guys have massed and
because by my force of gravity when
these light particles come close to one
another mass they should get
gravitationally focused they should be
attracted so there would be a deflection
in their paths they wouldn't be going
straight anymore they would get
deflected so he's really clever and it
turns out he calculated what the
deflection should be and it turns out
it's only a factor of two off from the
full general relativistic so remember
are a factor of two is a profound change
in our conception of gravity right
and so the deviations of what we're
going to see now are the deviations in
the paths of light rays the stretching
and the deflections carry a huge amount
of information both about the shape of
space as well as the masses the masses
that are causing the divots that the
photons are going to interact with
interfere with on their way to us so
they carry information both about the
geometry of the universe as well as the
masses that are causing those changes in
the geometry they're both encapsulated
in photons in light and we'll just see
that and so when I say I predicted these
deflections and he sort of you know his
instant fame really came from the
that you know one of the reasons why all
of us physicists are so gushy about
Einstein and gr is that this was sort of
an ex nihilo theory they wanted a set of
you know peculiar observations that were
in need of an explanation or the need of
a theory this was pure theory or as it
gets right and so then the question is
what can the theory predict other
observational things the theory can
predict so people went out and measured
and one of the key predictions was
gravitational lensing this bending of
light because you know underlying all of
this was a test of this conception of
space-time and curvature of space-time
due to masses and so on and so the
prediction was that if you went and you
know Arthur Eddington led a couple of
expeditions to go and make this
measurement during a total solar eclipse
and so what you have the actual
positions of stars during a solar
eclipse viewed from the earth we
actually see that the the apparent isn't
a part there's a difference in the
position of these stars so you can go
back six months later see where there
really are and there's a deflection you
can calculate that and they've matched
Einstein's prediction so that is really
what made him instantly famous because
this sort of experimental verification
of one of the key predictions of general
relativity okay so the kinds of objects
that I am interested in are very much
much more dramatic and these are
basically if you scale up this idea of a
galaxy with a Dark Matter halo these are
entities these clusters that are about a
thousand galaxies that are held together
by the gravity of a huge dark matter
halo a huge repository of dark matter
and because that the masses are so high
the deflections are not as fiddly as is
moving a star a little bit what they're
very very dramatic in fact the effects
are so dramatic that if you can think of
photons light as tubes or rays coming to
us sometimes the deformation is so
extreme the deformation in space-time
that the photon has to track so extreme
that one beam gets split into two and
what that means is that you end up
seeing two images three images five
images of the same object when in
reality you have one object okay and
I'll show you that how do we know that
the fingerprint remember you can go on
and take the spectrum
of any image and the spectra are
identical so well there's very low
probability that you know you would find
two objects that are in a configuration
that is explainable by gravitational
lensing that have identical spectra if
they are not actually images of the same
object so this is again a slightly more
sort of a figure that shows you what you
can actually measure when you see
gravitational deflection so you have a
distant galaxy you have light that's
coming out of the sky T stars in this
galaxy and you have a cluster of
galaxies the huge amount of dark matter
this is space-time you see a very huge
divot here and you see light that's bent
and so the normal path would have been
that so you can see that it's a very
dramatic this is like the most dramatic
bending that you can actually see in the
universe and do we see it absolutely so
this is one of the early images of a
cluster of galaxies called a ball 2218
and what you see are these distorted
shapes you see all these arcs so these
are distant galaxies that lie beyond the
cluster notice that the cluster is here
in the foreground and these distant
galaxies are what our image and we see
everything projected on the sky so we
can't actually tell what is where till
we get the spectrum and we know where
things are right so everything is
projected two-dimensional on the sky for
us so these arcs that you can pick out
by eye sitting right here right these
are gravitationally lensed object this
is a very distant galaxy turns out this
is actually imaged into five I'll just
show you some very very dramatic cases
right and so you can actually calculate
from these deflections you can actually
do the inverse problem which is to say
that you make an assumption from theory
of what the Dark Matter distribution
should look like in a region that is a
cluster and then you actually calculate
with a given prior distribution of
background galaxies what the distortion
map should look like how distorted
should these galaxies appear to us and
then you try to match it to this image
and then you back out from that the
actual accurate description of the mass
so it's sort of an iterative process and
you try
and to do this we need exquisite data
from say the Hubble Space Telescope you
cannot actually do it the kind of work
that I'm going to show you all the work
that is that I'm gonna show you today
from my research group
it needs the highest quality Hubble
Space Telescope data and the deepest
possible Hubble Space Telescope data as
well okay now how this is related to
mass how do we do this inversion problem
how do we back things out about
properties of dark matter so this is a
schematic that shows you that if dark
matter right this halo of dark matter
was vertically symmetric with a nice
spherical blob and you had a source that
lines up right behind then depending on
the alignment
I think this laser is gone unless I'm
butter-fingered okay I'm butter-fingered
okay so if you have a distant galaxy and
you see these deflections so if things
really line up this individual galaxy
could get stretched out into a ring okay
and this is seen these are all real
Hubble images so these are
configurations that are actually
detected and if you have a mass
distribution that has slightly different
symmetry so if it's ellipsoidal mass
distribution then you could get
something so this is a multiply imaged
quasar system it's called an Einstein
cross so you see actually five images of
the of a single quasar you have
something like this but of course nature
is not simple so it turns out that the
best description for what what I just
showed you this image of April 22 18 is
a combination of a lot of clumps of dark
matter superposed along with a smooth
distribution okay so that looks like the
best description for clusters of
galaxies and so but you know you might
have noticed here that alignment is
everything things kind of have to line
up to give you these most dramatic
effects that you can pick out right and
so depending depending on exactly where
a distant galaxy is behind the cluster
the image will be magnified distorted
you know cut into two etc and so
location is really really important so
when there is perfect alignment you can
get something called an Einstein ring so
this is an example of a beautiful it's
an individual galaxy this is not a
cluster so this is ours my you know a
cartoon galaxy with a big Dark Matter
halo and this is real data from how
image so a background galaxy which is
blue so it has young stars it's blue it
has been stretched out to be an almost
entire ring so what if the analysis done
as I said the process of analysis that
people like me do it has backed out and
shown that the lensing galaxy looks like
this this is the light distribution of
the guy obviously we don't see the dark
matter here this is the light
distribution of the galaxy that has a
dark matter halo that is doing the
lensing this is the distant source and
this is the distorted image that we see
so this is sort of the surgically
cleaned up image that shows you what
what happened where right so now I'm
going to show you quickly an animation
so you know nothing is moving in the
universe this is just to show you the
range of configurations that you can
likely see when you have a very large
cluster with lots of dark matter that's
doing the lensing so you can see these
stretched out configurations I'm just
showing you as an animation because now
you can pick out my eye when I show you
a Hubble image of which kind of
configuration like one long stretchy arc
with a lot of little arc lights so just
to remind you what's going on here is
that we have a uniform sheet of blue
circles okay there were all circles and
I've plunked a very massive cluster in
front of it and the cluster is causing
the distortions of the shape so you're
seeing a stretching you see a systematic
tangential stretching and you see these
guys that get completely distorted these
are the ones where light beam is
splitting and you're making multiple
images and so on and so the what we are
looking for in a cluster so a cluster
depending on how much mass you have so
as I said a cluster has about a thousand
galaxies and it has a smooth component
so this is what the smooth component
will do on top of it individual galaxies
in the cluster will have their own
little Dark Matter halos and they will
cause a tiny tiny tiny systematic
distortion on top of this dramatic
distortion and why is this important
this is important because one of the
things I'm going to show you is that
there is a lot of interesting physics
and potential clues the nature of dark
matter in the
molarity of dark matter in a cluster how
clumpy it is how the clumps are
distributed so I'll just go through a
couple of Hubble images to show you so
this is a very dramatic one in which you
have a galaxy that is shaped like a
cartwheel that actually has been imaged
five times so you see four here and the
fifth image is actually in the center
it's D magnified these guys are actually
magnified so you see some very very
dramatic effects so let's come back to
this good ol cluster Abell 2218 because
I'll try to show you how we have
reconstructed the clump distribution of
clumps of dark matter the entire
exquisite detail the distribution of
dark matter and then I'll show you why
that's important so before I show you
that let me just show you where our
theoretical understanding is okay this
is a movie that I need to start okay so
what this is showing you this is not
light it's actually dark matter just
mocked up to look like light so that
everyone feels comfortable with the
color scheme so that this is dark matter
and this is the way dark matter evolves
so that what we think constitutes dark
matter in the universe are particles
that are cold and collisionless
basically slow moving particles that
don't actually collide and actually hit
each other they kind of go past each
other okay so that it then this and the
dark matter distributions that we see in
the universe that have driven all the
structure formation in the universe the
driving seat of formation of all
galaxies everything we see out there is
that kind of particle best fits the
picture the cold collisionless dark
matter is called CDM and so we find what
you're seeing here is a cosmological
simulation with that kind of particle
that has been followed gravitation just
gravity go and form the structures and
it forms something that looks like this
cluster Abell 2218 and that's the reason
i've shown shown you that movie and this
is a zooming of a small region of the
universe so just to show you that so
this is this is again a simulation slice
where you can see this is where a
cluster would form where these filaments
I know it looks like neurons right so
you at these nodes you form clusters so
very massive objects format the places
where these filaments join so this is a
zoom in of a region that would form a
cluster later on and produce the lensing
okay this is why people like me are
obsessed with trying to get at the
granularity of dark matter so these are
two simulations with two different sets
of properties for dark matter one of
them is the cold dark matter model that
I just showed you we saw the movie the
other is warm dark matter and you can
visually see that warm dark matter is
not as clumpy and so if you were able to
statistically quantify how granular dark
matter was by making measurements then
you can actually discriminate between
these two possibilities and remember I
mean we in the absence as well as I
close I will show you in the absence of
really knowing what dark the dark matter
particle is right we are forced to come
up with these sort of indirect tests and
in a way astrophysics that's where
that's what astrophysics is going to
tell us it's going to be indirect as
always and it's particle physics that
will hopefully help us nail the particle
okay so this is the cluster of galaxies
so let me show show you really what
exactly people like me do so this is a
model for the gravity reconstruction of
the gravitational potential of the
cluster and these lines will show you
what would actually translate to little
troughs in space-time so you're actually
seeing the top view so this is the
deepest part this part is the deepest
part of the trough that you would make
in space-time so we're looking down and
we are seeing that's where most of the
dark matter is lumped and this is the
region where this bunny rabbit region is
the region where anytime you have a
galaxy behind that yellow bunny rabbit
it will be imaged multiplied because
there's a huge concentration of dark
matter that will split light beams and
so and what is shown here is all the
Hubble data these are the shapes of all
these galaxies you take all of this into
account and you produce this okay this
is the detailed distribution spatial
distribution of dark matter in that
region okay and and so what this shows
you is that there's some large scale
component that is smooth remember I
well it schematically showed you that
the what we understand currently about
clusters and then you have these smaller
scale clumps and these correspond to
individual Dark Matter halos associated
with galaxies in the cluster so we're
able to kind of parse out to see how the
Dark Matter so so dark matter it turns
out right is smeared lightly in the
universe everywhere but there are
regions where it's concentrated and
clusters are the regions where it's most
concentrated okay so now you can do this
exercise I just want to show you a few
plots to show you no it's not just you
can do it for one cluster but we kind of
have the data to do it for many many
clusters now so and here this is the one
where I showed you the galaxy was imaged
five times so and you can look at the
peaks of dark matter here and and see
that you know the this region has a high
concentration of dark matter and that
corresponds to the region where you have
these five galaxies so okay so where are
we then so when we can do this analysis
this is one of the till very recently
this was one of the deepest images taken
of the night sky where there was a
cluster and so this is what you see this
is what the Hubble Space Telescope see
this is a multi-wavelength picture so
it's a you know many wavelengths were
put together to give you this beautiful
optical image and what you don't see but
is they're gravitationally is this blue
stuff this is the reconstruction of the
Dark Matter distribution notice it's
extended notice it traces light it kind
of follows where light is right and but
it's very very extended right and so
what's really happened is currently I'm
involved in this incredible mapping
exercise it's the deepest look ever
taken of clusters by the Hubble Space
Telescope and it's six clusters have
been chosen because there are
dramatically good lenses and you may
remember I told you that a cluster is
going to be a dramatically good lens
when things line up when you have
objects right at the right distance
behind them and also when they're really
massive because that's when you get very
dramatic distortions right so this is
this is a very new result which we just
published last year so this as you can
see this image is exquisite
it's just beautiful you have so many
lenz objects that you can their more
than hundred background sources that are
multiplied image so that 300 pieces
right things that are imaged multiply
this is the reconstruction of the Dark
Matter distribution in this region of
the sky what you don't see and this is
in the blue haze and the shading of the
blue haze tells you where the
concentration so what's very interesting
is there appear to be regions I told you
that you roughly follow light then but
there are some regions where it appears
that you don't see a whole lot of
galaxies or light but you see clumps of
dark matter
okay so then as I said the key is to see
if you can discriminate or say something
about the particle properties of dark
matter by looking at these clumped
distribution right and the sort of the
dramatic contrast is between cold dark
matter and warm dark matter so it turns
out so this is sort of earlier work in
which we looked at the clump
distribution is the red histogram and
the black lines that you see are data
from the n-body simulation like the
simulation clip that i showed you from
that simulation under the assumption
that it's cold dark matter so it
actually fits quite well there's a place
where it doesn't look look like there's
something exciting going on there so it
turns out that is actually two clusters
that are merging into each other so you
don't actually expect it to fit so that
was then and now is now so this is the
state-of-the-art simulation where now
our understanding of how galaxies form
and everything has really gotten much
more sophisticated so this is very
recent data that i have just submitted
as a paper and i just wanted to share to
show you how much better our clump
distributions have become and how much
better and so i'm what am i after here
right so what we are really after right
i'm looking for gaps I'm looking for a
mismatch with the data and the
simulation because that suggests that
something in our picture isn't quite
right right so that's really what one is
looking for so here what we find is what
is interesting is the matches rather
good there's a little bit of an excess
of if you see the red histogram there's
an excess here compared to the curve
from simulations so I
turns out that one interesting thing
that we have just discovered is that
there's something amiss in simulations
there's some physical process that is
missing because the simulations are not
able to reproduce the radial
distribution of where the clumps are the
simulations are a little too diffuse and
universe seems to be more concentrated
and that could just be that these
lensing clusters right they're peculiar
regions these are not you know these are
very special regions so this is a
reconstruction notice how much better
it's become in terms of the granularity
that we can get visually you can already
see that we can find with this new data
set right we can do a lot better so this
is where we're at we have not found a
major gap in the theory and the data at
the moment some suggestive hints that
the ways in which we have been studying
these simulations these large computer
simulations are missing some potential
ingredients that have to do with the
dynamics so there is something perhaps
that the simulations need to be looked
at more carefully so I'm going to now
wrap very soon showing you how you can
actually get a dark energy as well with
the same data set so essentially the
strength of lensing depends on the mass
as we saw off the object as well as the
relative my said location is the
relative distance of the source from the
lensing mass and us so it depends on the
ratio of those distances so now consider
that you have two objects that are lens
by the same cluster I just told you
there are hundreds of galaxies that are
lensed by that cluster right so if you
look at any two representative objects
lens by the same cluster then but we can
by looking at constructing the mass
model and looking at the strength of
lensing we can figure out what the
geometry has to be for light propagation
from z2 to us versus z1 to us right so
any change in geometry so you can
actually use them to calibrate to find
out so if you have lots of multiple
images at various distances from the
center of a cluster so these are all
behind the all objects that are behind
and they could be at various distances
right so that's what we're looking for
then we can compare the strength of
lensing for objects if we know where the
objects are which we do if we have their
spectra and then you can figure out so
really what you're trying to do now is
you're calibrating the lens it's like
going to an optometrist right and
characterizing you know your glasses so
that's really what we're doing here so
if you do that if you calibrate the
lensing because if you know what is
where then you get a handle both on the
matter distribution and the geometry
because the photons are actually the
light rays are actually traversing
various bits of the universe not
identical but they're sampling different
bits of space-time so you can do that
and it turns out that clusters have been
particularly interesting and useful and
so this is a plot that shows you their
relative strength of dark energy versus
the contents matter contents of the
universe and the orange banana is the
current constraint from the lensing the
clusters that I've shown you and of
course right I mean here the power is in
combination combination of many
different independent lines of evidence
and then it's that overlap that gives
you the tightest constraint so as
zooming in on this orange region we see
that lensing has really helped us on top
of the supernovae on top of other
independent techniques to get at dark
energy sort of narrowing the error bars
kind of cornering and sort of trying to
define what this dark energy might be so
at the moment that dark energy appears
to be consistent with sort of einstein's
idea of the sort of vacuum energy of
space this lambda this cosmological
constant okay so I want to just wrap up
with the uncomfortable situation that
we're in right so so it makes news that
we've actually not detected dark matter
and we're looking for a very very long
time right so there's been one
experiment that an underground
experiment at a mine in Italy Gran Sasso
that called gamma that actually claimed
it's a controversial claim nobody has
been a
to replicate well they didn't try to
replicate but the new news I think what
is really exciting now is that there is
going to be your replication they're
going to be four independent experiments
are going to use the same detector
sodium iodide detectors put them
underground one in Gran Sasso itself one
in Korea one in Australia and one in
Spain and they're going to start taking
data in a few months so in a couple of
years there would be enough statistics
to actually see if the kinds of the
oscillation that you expect when dark
matter particles you know they're very
rare so they're very occasionally go
through us they go through us completely
but if you have they interact if you
have a sodium iodide crystal they make
jiggle the crystal and generate a little
light impulse and we may be able to
detect them that's the idea right and so
and there should be a seasonal variation
because we know the you know we know
that description we have description the
Dark Matter halo and we can calculate
the flux of particles as a function of
time so they should be a seasonal
variation with the Earth's orbit around
the Sun and that's what dama has claimed
to have found and people are now going
to replicate it so you know this is I
think fantastic because one of the
problems with all these expensive
experiments has been that nobody wants
to do a replication because you know
you're not you know fame and fortune are
not going to be given to you if you
replicate however it's really really
important right and one of the strengths
of science is that is that one has to
look for discrepancies as I started out
telling you that you know that God is in
the gaps as they say so why look for
gaps right so if you look at history and
you look at the you know the deviation
there was a deviation in the orbit of
Uranus I mean from Newton's prediction
this is I know life a la Newton and this
French bright French mathematician
astronomer or being lava here predicted
that there should be another planet that
was actually perturbing everything
beyond Uranus and Neptune was discovered
ICTA did mathematically predicted what
the orbit should be for an afternoon
they found Neptune now it turns out that
there was a as the data got better right
so this is when you know the data got
better and they know
is that mercury there was a bit of a
glitch that didn't fit and so our main
livery I said oh great you know what I
think there's another planet between the
Sun and mercury and let's call it Vulcan
and that's what's going on people look
for walkin a few people found it
actually it wasn't found it wasn't there
right so it turns out that that gap
right the gap in understanding the
mismatch and data for Uranus showed you
that there was Neptune but Newton's laws
were intact right within the same
framework the deviation in the orbit of
mercury actually could be explained only
by Einstein's conception of general
relativity the fact that mercury is
closest to the Sun and it samples the
divet that's produced in space-time by
the Sun very closely so there are some
aberrations in its orbit right and so
notice that when you have a mismatch you
can either a theory needs a little bit
of refinement but survives intact or the
entire theory it's pointing to the
existence of an entire new theory and
again you know Einstein didn't set out
to explain mercury it just turned out
right that his theory managed to so I
think that when we see so at any rate at
least one of my goals is to see if there
are any irreparable cracks that appear
in a robust theory right robust cracks
cracks that persist with many different
independent observations and we know
that some of the gaps in our
understanding right could come could
signal the
B could give us a clue or a glimpse of
another another grander more powerful
explanation a more powerful theory that
explains much much more so anyway I will
just stop here and thank you all for
your attention
[Applause]
[Music]
so you've leaped there's a certain sort
of shoe going through the audience here
keep those questions coming because
otherwise I'm gonna die up here you've
linked very well dark matter and dark
energy in terms of observation
particularly in terms of lensing around
the galaxy clusters is there any linkage
do you think in them in terms of what
they are or is it just that I mean
conspiracy theory says all mysteries are
linked right so these two mysteries
showed up at roughly the same time we
call both of them dark they must be some
two versions the same thing not so dark
is just you know phraseology for
astronomers when they don't understand
something it's merely that don't
understand you just put the prefix dark
and then you feel that you know you
you'll give it a name and you think you
understand right
no I think there have been models there
are models where people are trying
really hard to maybe combine the two but
there is nothing successful at the
moment that's nothing noteworthy where
they are in any way linked the the
current description that still survives
all the gaps in the test so far is that
dark matter are these sort of cold
collisionless particles and so the thing
is we really need to get on with it and
discover those particles and I think
that I'm really hopeful that if these
replication experiments actually see
that signal then we have something when
there are other little tantalizing hints
from particle physics that it's not
clear how they could be related to a
dark matter particle at the moment but
recently the LHC Atlas and CMS the two
experiments that did find the Higgs have
recently found a sort of a slight
signature of a new particle 750 GeV that
it has a right kind of mass it could be
interesting
either as a Dark Matter particle itself
or be related in some way to what could
be a Dark Matter particle so what is
really seen is sort of a particle that
is decaying to give you two photons this
is a little bit of an excess there and
so it's signature or something new
that's unexpected so it's something that
was not predicted by any theory but at
the moment can kind of be accommodated
so we need a lot more data to understand
it better and at first of all these two
experiments don't detect it to the same
level of significance so we they need to
collect more data and then maybe there's
something there so I think the clues
honestly for Dark Matter are really
going to come from the detection of the
particles we really need the particles
so you think Dark Matter is likely to be
solved sooner than dark energy in the
sense of what get solved I mean it's the
title of your talk for you we may have
we may have some kind of theoretical you
know the problem is that whatever
explanation you have to come up with say
for dark energy kind of man has to hang
with the rest very successful theory
that explains a lot of phenomena so you
know we need an explanation for dark
energy that kind of really hooks in and
it's consistent with everything else so
it's unclear you know how soon that
might come on the dark energy which is
sort of even more than dark matter it
sounds like fate of the universe story
you mentioned in passing that it's sort
of cut in at a certain point after that
first four hundred thousand years what
is known about when and how it cut in
right so um from so one of the key ways
as you can imagine right so the change
in X the dramatic change in expansion
history when you start having
accelerating expansion is that the sort
of distance between pairs of objects is
much much farther away when dark energy
starts to kick in so you can start
looking at a signature in the clustering
of galaxies how close galaxies are to
each other
a measure of when and look at how the
clustering changes of a cosmic time to
see when you see the signature and we do
see that now quite clearly and we can
actually figure out that you know in the
last five to eight billion years is when
it actually kicked in so remember that
time scale of the universe it's not a
linear time scale right so the age of
the universe depends on the contents in
society complicated so so out to
redshift for those of you who sort of
read a lot of popular astronomy so we
think it kind of kicks in at a redshift
of two ish and we see that signature
quite clearly so we know when it starts
to kick in and become important so
there's an acceleration is the rate of
acceleration changing accelerating
decelerating or the the you mean the the
next order effect is yeah maybe not yet
we don't have conclusive measurements
but that's the next state step to look
at how the acceleration itself changes
so one of the interesting things people
are looking for and that you would for
example other reasons I like clusters is
that if that acceleration is changing
with time something a cluster would you
would see it very distinct signature in
this data so that's what people are look
at the moment there is no evidence for a
change but we'll have to see I think
when the experiments get better and the
data gets better keep watching for
billions of years hopefully rich Nauman
asks comment in the possibility that
there are different types of dark matter
for example outside of galaxies or right
there in the center in the plane I mean
obviously I mean you know it is quite
possible that you have different kinds
of dark matter but you know the simplest
possible Occam's razor explanation you
have like one kind let's try to figure
that figure that out right so what we do
know is that remnants of stories would
leave little black holes neutron stars
and things these sort of dark objects
that are don't actually emit light they
could constitute you know dark matter in
say specific places the center of a
galaxy center of a cluster globular
cluster or something so it turns out
that when you look at
the cosmic inventory and look at all the
stars that have formed over the age of
the universe and all the little black
holes that could have been left over
from them and so on it's not enough to
explain all the dark matter that we need
to explain the formation of all the
galaxies that we see so you could have
other things constitute you know a few
percent here a few percent there kind of
thing but it can't be the bulk of dark
matter so we think that the bulk the
bulk properties this sort of smeared
everywhere kind of dark matter which is
cold dark matter it's probably the
dominant is a dominant component this
room for other things contributing a
little bit interesting kind of
historical question Freedman Einstein's
seemed to avoid the data realities of
their research that implied to an
expanding universe the question is what
are we avoiding today can't avoid that
one but the question is you know what do
we scientists not want to believe in the
sense that they didn't what's just too
painful to contemplate is there anything
you would consider in that category
embarrassing plate for hey now I mean
I've I I think that you know if you look
at the you know the case that I've been
making a bhoot dark matter and dark
energy empirically detected yeah so we
can't there is no escape from data now I
mean then that was that then and now is
now so we have it says and I think what
is really powerful as you said right I
mean the reason why a lot of us think
this is the golden age of cosmology it's
sort of the interplay of ideas and
instruments right and data today that's
really unique there's more theories than
data a while back and now we got more
data than theories that match it and how
all that changed so you've been getting
stuff from the Hubble Space Telescope
the James Webb Space Telescope comes on
pretty shortly
how will that affect your and everybody
else's astrophysics right I mean I think
with every new telescope about the Webb
telescope in the house differences so
the James Webb telescope
these filters basically the eyes through
which it's looking at the universe it's
more sort of the infrared so which is
the longer wavelengths the redder
wavelengths and these are the
wavelengths in which one you have stars
new stars that form that have there's a
lot of dust around them this is the
radiation this is the reradiating stuff
so the blue stuff is absorbed and it's
emitted the red word so you see a lot
more of the dynamical stuff that's
happening the reprocessing that's
happening in the universe dust in the
universe will be revealed by JWST so
it's almost like opening a new set of
windows into the universe and if you see
you know so for example if you the
cluster of galaxies that I just showed
you I showed you all these optical
images if you go and look at that same
region with an x-ray telescope that
picks up the most energetic photons
which are in the x-ray short wavelength
you find that it looks very diffuse
because there's a huge amount of hot gas
that is sitting in that gravitational
potential that you don't see in the
Hubble image at all and you see it only
in the x-ray so the idea is that when we
create a model then we have to reconcile
all these different ingredients and
views of the object so JW is going to be
really really important in our
understanding of like the first stars
that formed that are probably extincted
a lot by dust
therefore the radiation would be
radiating the infrared wavelengths and
so I think it's going to open the new
window into the first stars in the first
galaxies in the first black holes say
more about but you haven't talked much
about black holes no I know that's part
of your study what do you hope to get
from James Webb telescope in your black
hole or so you know I have been working
in terms of black holes I've been
working most recently on the formation
of the first black holes and in
particular a new way to form them which
is to form them to be very massive from
the get-go so you basically have large
lumps of gas that become gravitationally
unstable then coalesce and form a very
massive black hole to start with the
normal picture is that you form the
first black hole when the first star
exhausts all its fuel and leaves the
remnant and that's a very tiny little
black hole
that it turns out is not enough to
explain the quasars that you see in the
universe and you as you look further and
further out you're seeing these quasars
very bright quasars that are powered by
extremely supermassive black holes in
place when the universe was just a
billion years old so how did that happen
you don't actually have enough time to
grow a fiddly little hole to that mass
so you have to make a more massive black
hole from the get-go so that's a model
that me and my students and postdocs
have been working on for many years and
that makes very distinct predictions on
the total number of very massive growing
black holes that will glow in the
infrared that should be seen by JWST so
I'm very very excited about what the
James Webb Space Telescope will uncover
very nervous about how it has to all
open up in space right especially
because recently we lost this incredible
satellite that I was very hopeful about
for black holes he told me the Japanese
satellite it disintegrated after being
successfully launched so without giving
us data so so the that the material
you've published on black holes make
specific predictions for what the data
will show from the James Webb should
look like for those objects and how you
would identify them and so it's very
exciting the either right or wrong or
further puzzled well you know when I
started doing this work on trying to
compare with you know cold dark matter
models I was quite young right it was 10
or 12 years ago and I thought really
famous find something that doesn't match
I'm gonna find a crisis right I didn't I
mean it all kind of fits right and we
just got a good it so we don't have to
we want to completely throw out the
theory but it would have been nice
[Laughter]
Susan asked so everything begins with so
and this party we're just dark matter
and dark energy can't anything about
multiple universes and the multiverse is
that impinge on your domain or not no
but now I have beliefs at least I use
that word very very consciously okay I
mean I like the idea of a multiverse
because you know the I kind of alluded
to this a little bit well you know our
universe can be described with these
with a set of six numbers that kind of a
few of them appear in those Friedmann
equations so you go out and you measure
them and you just need six numbers to
describe the past present future of the
universe and if some of these numbers
were slightly different from what we
measure them to be we wouldn't be here
life when we won't have had this cosmic
we won't have had this particular cosmic
drama unfold the way it did right and so
why these six numbers and to me it seems
like a convenient out and I am admitting
it's a convenient out to just say that
you know there could be other universes
out there with different combinations of
six different values that would have you
know different ingredients different
geometries you know and different
expansion histories and so on and so I'm
happy to accommodate the belief that we
could have a multiverse with many other
instantiations of so the reason it's a
belief is that at the moment it is hard
to see how just by how we've constructed
our theories right so the cosmic speed
limit is the speed of light
and so the observable universe is a
finite limit and then we can can't see
beyond it and any other bubble universe
is somewhere beyond our reach so by
construction we can't get evidence the
way we normally think about in science
you know observational evidence in so on
for this hypothesis right and so it's a
belief but then you know I am open
because can you imagine
I don't think Copernicus would have
thought even though he did an amazing
thing he moved the pivot from the earth
you know to the Sun I don't think he
could have imagined that we would have
landed on the moon
it was beyond the realm or the scope of
imagination for him right and so you
know I'm open to the idea that maybe
there will be breakthroughs that will
somehow there are already some
calculations that suggest that maybe
these bubble universes could have
collided and you could have some tremor
that you might see in the CMB there's no
the data is not good enough there's
nothing that suggested that that's a
fruitful explanation at the moment but
you know who knows a few hundred years
from now if we haven't destroyed our
planet and we're still here and you know
maybe we'll find something different
that might be evidence for the
multiverse sure a lot of people who were
counting on one level or another science
fiction writers fair number of
physicists any of the multiverse turns
out not to be the case that by now would
almost be a surprise for people um
here's a question from anonymous asking
how does a collisionless particle get
detected in the experiments you
mentioned in Spain and well yeah that's
a great question okay it just kind of
passes through so you kind of have to
wait for it I don't remember one be
opening passes Serena's collisionless
how do you know that happened I don't
know a crystal is your crystal just by
it's my house okay it's master it's
passing through and it changes the
crystal structure and you can we have
instruments that will then convert that
into a light impulse if it goes through
and of course you have to worry very
carefully about everything else that can
Jago that right but you know I don't
know I'm very hopeful right I mean look
at LIGO I mean their detection was just
incredible so the gravity waves yeah
that they could they could characterize
all other effects that could mimic the
real thing extremely well right because
it was a precision measurement right the
strain was ten to the minus twenty-one I
mean it was really quite something so I
mean I think that Dark Matter
experiments are the sensitivities are
not you know quite there yet but you
know people are building bigger and
bigger racks with bigger crystals a lot
bigger
detectors see one of the problems with
the dark matter is sight so we are
groping in this space so what we're
really looking for is a parameter space
is the mass of the particle and the
interaction cross-section it's a weak
interaction cross-section so there are
lots of the space that we know are ruled
out if we believe in the current
theoretical idea so we think that you
know we've kind of really understood the
particle content of the universe
and the standard models right we can
kind of rule out regions but the the
available parameter space is still vast
enough that we kind of don't you know
there's room there's a lot of so we have
detectors that are looking in particular
rangers again guided by what we think
you know the a pocket which this dark
matter particle could have formed in the
early universe therefore the kind of
mass range you know the kind of mass
range that would conveniently solve the
Dark Matter problem in a way so this is
literally I mean a drunk looking for
keys under that sort of thing it's not
that bad but it's kind of close so like
these keys are evenly distributed so lot
of keys the right place to look is under
the light but it also sounds like the
pretty rare if you're you know waiting a
long time for one to go by your crystal
this is very dilute this dark matter I
know given where we are in the solar
system the question is as I said dark
matter is smeared lightly everywhere in
the universe and there are places where
it slumped we actually happened to be in
a pretty location away from the center
of our galaxy at a place where the Dark
Matter density is actually quite low so
it's our location as well that folds
into this you describe the halo of dark
matter around these galaxies it's very
thin out there but it adds up to a lot
cuz there's so much there's a lot in the
center so it's heaped in the center and
so there's a very particular functional
form for how the density of dark matter
scales as a function of radius from the
center of a galaxy so there's a nice
peak it's kind of heaped in the center
and then it kind of falls off as we go
out but out to some distance yeah quite
a large distance but it kind of really
uses and it's really mergers with what
is cosmically smear
would we be better off as dark matter
detectors if we were in a galaxy cluster
of some consequence sure maybe yeah but
you know I think that but we're not that
is so hard to fix say a little more
about difference between the worm dark
matter and cold dark matter that one
kind of went by quick and it sounds like
your findings are going in the direction
of cold dark matter and clumpiness are
there opposing theories that have other
things to say well I mean so in terms of
the one thing that I did not mention
right and there was a reason I didn't
mention is that you know the people
tried the the sort of the historical
story which I closed about not trying to
change the theory versus amend the
theory slightly so one kind of
alternative to dark matter that has been
proposed is a modification of Newtonian
dynamics and but this this is not has
not been successful in fact it was very
exciting because it was kind of
successful so they changed the force law
and they changed how that falls off if
you will vaguely that's sort of what
they did and what they that is a
bekenstein a Milgram and pack and shine
to scientists in Israel and it turns out
that they could kind of explain away the
need for dark matter on the scales of
galaxies they could kind of say well you
know it's really the modification of
gravity and but the place where the
whole thing falls apart is that that
kind of theory which has no Dark Matter
cannot explain the light bending no
matter how sophisticated they make it
they have not been able to bend bend
light and they actually it's on the
scale of clusters that the whole thing
falls apart and that's why I like
clusters because they've already
discriminated and ruled out so once Sara
so the the thing about Darkman therefore
there are actually as I said no there
are there are a few gaps so one of the
gaps that is there in the current cold
Dark Matter model
is that the inner regions of galaxies
the expectation of how dark matter
should be the expectations it should be
a very peaky distribution and it appears
in a lot of galaxies in particularly the
low luminosity galaxies that they're the
Dark Matter distribution that you infer
from the data is actually like a core
like a smooth mirror in the center so
you know it's like having a nice little
peak that's been smoothed out and the
one explanation for that is that you
have these if it's slightly different
kind of Dark Matter particle a Dark
Matter particle whose mass is such that
it's sort of free streams and it doesn't
clump on very small scales as a
characteristic scale below which it
doesn't actually clump and that's why
the distributions are so much more
smoother than that of coal dark matter
model so it turns out that again you can
use the warm dark matter you can invoke
it and say well I can kind of explain
away the centers but then when we try to
tie that to the end the amount of dark
matter that we need and all the other
observations right there's a
characteristic scale that should show up
in you know the dark matter in actually
is as you have these fluctuations in the
dark matter density of little heaps and
little troughs and then they amplify
over time and that's why you get that
network that you see right so it turns
out that the warm dark matter would
actually then you wouldn't see a lot of
those networks and we actually see them
so so that you know particle again I
think there's room for that kind of
particle being a small contributor to
the whole sort of dark matter bucket
right so you have this other thing and
then you have some other small pieces
like little black holes maybe some a
little bit of smattering of warm dark
matter so their constraints on how much
that could be but it cannot be the
entire inventory of dark matter that we
infer to connect this to prop culture
from that there was a movie recently
that took black holes very seriously oh
that's that not that's not relevant to
dark matter but it's relevant to black
hos and is one of my favorite recent
movies interstellar and so what I really
liked about that how many here saw
interstellar everyone
I mean this is San Francisco you must it
was awesome the visual effects were
fabulous right so this is what was
interesting to me about the movie and I
sort of wrote a very cursory review of
it was that the calculations of light
bending by this huge black hole called
Gargantua that those equations were
actually Einstein's equations that were
solved for light bending so they
actually did the computation and they
also had you know and so they had kept
for an who is the one of the sort of
leading minds in terms of understanding
black holes he was a co-producer in that
movie so so I think his job was to make
sure that no laws of physics were
violated when this movie was made but
that he was willing to kind of
extrapolate just a little bit beyond
what is known right I know for me the
coolest thing about that movie other
than the visualizations and the black
holes and stuff is the fact that a
scientific paper emerged from the making
of that movie in that visualization a
peer-reviewed paper so how often has
Hollywood collaborated with Kip Thorne
so how did these movie makers wind up
co-authoring a scientific paper what did
they do that was actually calculated the
paths of light rays around the black
hole and because they had heavy-duty
computational equipment they found there
was some interesting nonlinear effects
that hadn't been noticed before and keep
wrote that up in Hollywood had stronger
computers than Caltech is that one
element in that particular yes that
visualizing I think it's cool the place
was called double negative I forget what
they would call I'm blanking out now but
that company yes
well you know I mean they were they're
incentivized to do these calculations
possibly right they I mean the movie I
think minted money it just was so
popular everywhere in case there's any
questions lingering on how art and
science intersect this is one and you
got lots of science coming I hope
there's artists paying attention this is
going to be great we're gonna have fun
this century thanks a lot
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you